in this course slow button will teach
you how to incorporate 3D models into
your react websites and product pages
slow button is a senior full stack
developer and popular course creator and
welcome to this tutorial in this one
you're gonna learn how to create this
amazing react website with astonishing
3D animations we are gonna learn how to
use webgi SDK to manipulate and find
your 3D models then we're gonna learn
how to display them in your website
using webgi and 3js and then we're gonna
learn how to animate these 3D models
using gsap and webgi we are also going
to create this preview mode where
visitors can play around with their 3D
model and apart from that we're gonna
learn how to optimize these animations
for mobile devices and at the end we're
going to build this project and deploy
so be ready to learn a ton of stuff some
prerequisites for this tutorial is to
have basic HTML CSS and JavaScript
knowledge if this video reaches 1000
likes on my channel I will be releasing
the full source code on my GitHub
otherwise you may want to check
patreon.com for
my support and full source code so what
are you waiting let's get yourself
comfortable and let's start
code with slova
and welcome back so this is the website
that we're gonna be building in this
tutorial
the first thing that we need to do is to
head over to github.com
here I have created these 3D website
startup package for you guys
the URL of this repository is going to
be in the description box below but you
can see the URL here as well
so what we need to do here is to
download this package
this way it's going to be very easy for
us to set up the project and get going
with programming
so head over to this code button and
click on it there are multiple ways to
download this repository but the easiest
way is to download a zip so click here
download zip
wait for a couple of seconds and the
file has been downloaded now let's find
it in the file explorer
so click on the Explorer icon
and in my case it's in the downloads
folder
now let's right click on it and extract
here so we want to extract the content
of this folder
now open this folder in your code editor
for me it's Visual Studio code
so open the visual studio code
file
open folder
downloads
and iPhone 3D website starter Dash Main
I will click yes I trust the authors
let me zoom in this a little bit
and let's see what we have generated in
this Repository
first you have this public folder on top
here are all the files that you don't
want to import using the module system
in your application
so this could be the files that you
import dynamically
the next folder is the source folder
essentially this is the core of our
application inside of the source we have
this assets folder as well
in this folder you can store images svgs
fonts whatever you need
all the images that we are going to be
using for this website are already
downloaded and set here so you don't
have the bottle with downloading
separately
next we have this app.jsx component
which is the only component at the
moment that we have in our application
but generally this is going to be the
root of our application and everything
that we put inside of this component
will be displayed next to our component
we have this index.css file here I
already imported all the fonts that we
need and generated all the code that we
need for our application as the purpose
of this tutorial is not to learn CSS but
to learn how to animate 3D models
you can think of this file as a UI
Library so all the classes already have
been written for you and all you have to
do is add the proper classes to the
sections in your HTML file
the next component is main.jsx file
this is the main file where we are
importing our app component our styles
and we are rendering our app component
inside of the root div
and this div is located inside of the
index.html file here so entire
application is going to be generated
here
and you generate that using this create
root method from react down
apart from that we have this
package.json file as well
in case you are watching this tutorial
years ahead and this repository doesn't
exist here are all the dependencies that
you need to install in order to make
this project running
let me just close this folder so that
you can see entire urls
like so
and the dev dependencies as well
now let's close this package.json file
and the last file that we have here is
veet.compic.jis file
wheat is a front-end building tool and I
use it over create react app because of
its performance benefits all this file
does is set up some configuration files
for react but you don't have to worry
about anything because it's going to do
the configuration for you
and it has better performance than the
webpack so let's close this file and now
let's install our packages to open the
terminal I will just drag from the
bottom in the vs code
like so and I will choose here git Bash
let me close the Powershell
now run the npm install command
and hit enter
after couple of seconds you can see that
we added this number of packages
and here on the top we have this node
underscore modules new folder generated
for us which contains all the folder
packages that we need for our project so
let's close it
now let's start our application by
running the command npm run Dev
let's face it for a couple of seconds
we should start a development server for
us
and just open the URL from the console
and as you can see our application is
successfully running let me just zoom in
a little bit so you can see it better
and the other thing that you can notice
is that some default Styles have already
been applied to this application like
background color and foreground color
so this is a good start already
the first thing that I want to build is
the navigation on top
so we want to replicate the apple style
here
so let's build this component first let
me close this file
and let's get back over to our Visual
Studio code
reduce the size of the terminal we don't
need it
and now let's create a new folder here
inside of the source folder name this
file as components or actually folder
essentially all the components that we
create for application are going to be
stored here as we don't have multiple
pages in our application we only have
the components for this app.js file so
let's add a new file and name this file
as nav.jsx
and this is short for navigation
component
let's import react from the top and I'm
using Code snippet extension for faster
development
if you want to have exactly the same
shortcuts as I'm building in this
tutorial go to the extensions here and
just install this simple react Snippets
code extension
now let's close it
and let's generate new functional
component so we can run the shortcut FFC
for functional syntax component
and now enter the name of the component
for us it's nav
without the e on the end so remove the e
and we got generated this code snippet
so what this code snipper does it
generate a dysfunctional component with
empty return statement and also export
default on the bottom so let's start
writing some jsx code first let's add an
app
here
this now will have a class name
of nav Dash wrapper
next let's add additional div inside of
this now
and this day we'll have a class name
and the class name is snap Dash content
inside of this div we're gonna place our
Northern list component with all the
links for the navigation
and we created this nav element for the
semantic purposes and this tip is just
for styling purposes
is we need to apply some background
color to our navigation and also to
center it and apply some styles to our
fonts as well
so let's create an ordered list here
in this list we'll also have a class
name
and the name of the class name is list
Dash styled
the first element of this list is going
to be Apple logo so let's just review it
for a second
open the browser
and if I open the final version you can
see on navigation here on top on the
left we have first logo and then we have
all these links and on the right side we
have here search icon and this like
store purchase icon as well so let's
build that
let's get back to our nav.jsx file
and let's import the logo first on top
so type the following import
logo from
assets folder images
logo Dot scg
now let's add the list item here
we don't need any classes for the list
item and inside of the list item let's
add the image
so this image will hold the logo
let's add the source property
and passing the logo
next we want to add the alt attribute as
well
and let's write Apple
now let's run the default formatting so
right click and format the document
nice and let's save and preview
but before we do that actually we need
to include it inside of our app.jsx file
so here in the import section write the
following import now from components for
slash nav
and let's remove this hello text
and place the nav self-causing component
now let's save it and open the browser
close this file
and there you go
you can see that we have this white
background and our logo here on the left
let me just zoom out a little bit
because it's this is too much like so
now let's add the links
open an app.jsx again and close this
app.jsx file
now let's add additional
list element or item and inside of this
one we want to add anchor tag
let's add a class name to this link
the class name is going to be link Dash
styled
and we are not going to be adding the
link attribute but on the real website
obviously you want to add that as well
for the first link
the name is going to be store of this
link so let's format this document
let's save and let's preview
at the moment the link is on the top
right corner but when we add all the
other links it's going to fall in place
here next to the logo so let's add them
so let's copy paste this link a couple
of times
because we're just going to be changing
the name of the links
the first one is store the second one is
Mac
the next one should be iPad
then we have the iPhone
next to iPhone we have watch
now let's paste a couple more
next to the watch we have airpods
then we have TV
and home
next we have entertainment
next to that we have accessories
and after that let's paste another one
and here let's place
support
okay okay and now we just need two more
links
the first one is going to be for the
search icon
so let's add an image element
let's add a source
attribute
and let's add an alt
for alt let's write search
and let's import the search icon on the
top here
write the following import
search from
assets images
search.svg
like so and let's Import in the image
here
and let's do the same for the second
link
except that we're going to use the
different image
let's rename this one as store
and let's rename the alt attribute as
well
and now let's import the store SPG as
well copy the search import and just
rename from search to store
let's save this one again let's format
this document
and let's preview
we got this failed import R so we are
missing one letter here images
and here as well images so let's save
and let's preview again
and now it works
with this we have completed our
navigation
and let's proceed on building this
Jumbotron so let's close this page and
let me open Visual Studio code
and now let's add a new file in the
components folder
name this file as geometron.jsx
once again let's import the react on top
and let's generate the functional
component using the code Snippets
name of this component is going to be
Jumbotron
and let's just add some placeholder text
now let's import this component inside
of the app component
so on the top import
Jumbotron from components forward slash
Jumbotron and let's place it here next
to the nav
make it a self-closing tag
now let's say this in preview for a
second
it's loaded correctly so we can continue
let's close the app.jsx file and let's
close the navigation as well
now let's add some jsx code
here I want to add a root div
Dy will have a class name and the name
of this class name is going to be
Jumbotron
Dash section
and the second one is going to be
wrapper
the first thing that I want to create
inside is the title so add h2 tag and
let's add a class name of title the tact
is going to be new
below that you want to add another image
here we're going to display iPhone 14
pro but actually we're going to use an
image for it not the text and although
this sounds like a weird solution
but I probably wanted to keep the
original look of the text on the logo
which cannot be a hundred percent
replicated with CSS or at least they
wanted to be sure it's rendered
correctly on all devices
so let's add an image element
and add a class name of logo
Source we're going to add just in a
second and let's add an ALT attribute
right here iPhone 14 pro
like so
and let's import this image
but here in the import section let's
import iPhone
from
assets
slash Images slash iPhone
Dash 14.
14 Dot jpg
and let's place this one
and the source attribute here
now let's preview that one
and there you go
let's proceed
let's set a text below this image
so add a paragraph and this paragraph
also has a class name
class name is text
and the text is big and
bigger
which means that they have versions that
are big and bigger
below that let's set a span
it will hold the description
let's add a class name as well
and the name of the class is description
and the text is going to be just some
paying options
from
1.62 dollars
per month for 24 months
or
999 dollars before
Trading
we want to replicate exactly the same
text as they have on their website
let's see what we have for now
and this big title looks beautiful with
the gradient and apple is well known for
the Simplicity and Aesthetics
next below this we need to add a buy
button and learn more so let's do that
so here below this description let's add
an ordered list
and this unordered list has a class name
name of the class name is going to be a
links
let's add a first list item
and this one is going to have a button
inside of it
and here we're gonna say pi
Also let's add a class name to this
button and it's going to be simple
button
also we can add an href
but actually we don't need it
now let's copy paste this list item
and for the second one we want to add an
anchor tag
this link is going to say
learn more
and let's add a class name
link
and let's save it now
let's preview
boom this looks beautiful let's continue
and the last part is that we want to add
an image on the bottom and we're going
to have on the hand holding an iPhone so
let's import image for that
write the following import and name
these images holding iPhone from
assets
we want to get into the images and the
name of this image is iPhone Dash hand
dot PNG
and now let's add an image on the bottom
here
after the unordered list let's add an
image now let's add a class name the
class name is going to be iPhone Dash
image
source is going to be
holding
iPhone
and let's add an ALT which is going to
be iPhone
let's see how it looks
and boom this looks great
later in this tutorial we're gonna add
3D model object here next to this phone
so it's not going to look so empty
and also when we add additional sections
we want programmatically to scroll down
to these sections clicking on learn more
here so we're going to add that later
now let's add those additional sections
so let's get back here
and in the components folder let's add
additional file and name this file as
sound section.jsx
let me show you what we're going to be
building in this section
and when we open the final version
you can see that on this second section
you have more information about the
sound and the new sound system that's
why I call it sound section
so let's build that
again let's import react from the top
and let's create functional component
all using the code Snippets the name of
this component is going to be sound
section
let's add a placeholder text here in the
return statement
and let's import this component in the
app file
so let's open the app.jsx
and import
on the top
sound section
and let's place it below the Jumbotron
make this one a self-closing tag as well
let's save the app
and let's close both of these
let's just preview it so that we are
sure
that is connected properly
and there you go hello
let's add some jsx code
so let's remove this placeholder text
let's add a div
and this day will have a class name
the name of the class name is sound Dash
section
and let's add a wrapper class as well
inside a wrapper let's add one more div
and this div will be a div with a class
name of body
and let's add additional div
and this one will have a class name
of sound section
content and let's add additional class
just content
you may be wondering why we have so many
divs
but the purpose of them is to have the
proper structure and to have proper
Styles applied to them
the first thing inside of the content is
going to be the title so add an H2
element and this one is going to have a
class name
simply title
and here we're gonna say new sound
system
like so
and below that let's add a paragraph
this paragraph has a class name text
and the text is going to be feel the
base
like so
below that we want to add a span with
payment options and let's add a class
name
of description
for the text
I can copy from the final version
so I don't have to type out
here
let me close the folders and let me
format
let's save and preview
now the reason why you can't see
anything on this section is because this
section has opacity set to zero
and later we'll use gsap to add a fading
effect here so let's remove the opacity
so we can see it actually
let's open our index.css file and let's
search for sound section
and let's find the opacity zero and
let's comment this out
so now if we save it close this file
close the folder
and let's see again
and there you go
we just need to fix this typo and add a
button and a link
so let's do that here there's a typo
should be filled
and here after the description let's add
an ordered list with the links
let's add a class name of
just links
and let's add a first list item
inside of this one we're gonna have a
button similar like on the Jumbotron
text will be just by
and let's add a class name
of button
simple as that
now let's add additional list item
for the second one we're gonna have a
link
so error anchor element and let's add a
class name of Link
the text is going to be learn more
now let's format the document
and let's preview
there you go this is the final version
of this section except if you're gonna
have iPhone here
once we add our 3D object and this learn
more button
we're going to implement scrolling once
we add the next section
but since we added this section we can
Implement actually this one so once we
click on the learn more we want the page
to scroll down to this section so let's
do that
so let's open the geometron component
and here on the top
let's add a function
name this function
handle learn more
this is a fat Arrow function first we
want to Target our sound section so use
the document
dot query selector
and then let's target the sound Dash
section
and we want to store this inside of the
constant named element
we want to take the top position of this
element and scroll down so let's use the
window
dot scroll to method
this method takes an object as argument
and this object receives a couple of
parameters the first one is the top
position
and then we can use our element
from the document query selector and
call the get bounding client rect
call this method this method will return
the position and move on to access the
top position
and let's add an optional chaining
operator
which basically says if this element is
undefined don't execute this function so
this component doesn't get an error the
next property is the left we want to set
the Left To Zero as we don't need any
horizontal scrolling and the last
property is behavior
which we're gonna set to smooth
so that we have a smooth scrolling so
let's use this
method that we just created or write a
function
and here on the learn more
let's add on click method
and let's pass this function
and now let's try this
let's scroll up to the Jumbotron section
and once we click on the learn more
boom we get scroll down here and now
let's build the last section of this
website so if I go over to the final
version and if you click on the learn
more
you can see that we got scroll down to
This brilliant display section let's
build that one
so let's get back to the visual studio
code
let's close these files and let's add a
new file in the components folder it's a
new file and name this file as display
selection Dot jsx
again let's import the react
using the code snippet and then let's
generate new functional component this
one is going to be called display
section
let's add
placeholder text
and let's Import in the app.jsx file
so let's import it first
import the space section from components
slash display section and let's place it
next to the sound section
so just place the display section
component and make it a self-going tag
save this close the app.jsx file and
let's preview
there is no errors in the component we
get the hello here on the bottom left
and let's add all the components or
actually the elements that we need
let's remove this
placeholder text and let's add a div
this deal will have a class name of the
display section
and also let's add a wrapper class as
well
similar to other section let's add h2
tag and a class name of title
the text is going to be new
and below this text let's add a
paragraph
with a class name of text
and here we're going to say brilliant
with a DOT
and let's add a span
to the class name of description
and let me copy paste the text as it's a
little bit longer
so let me open
the final version and let me just copy
this text
okay let me close that
and let paste the text here I will close
the folder and let me format the
document so it's more readable
and below that let's add the button
so again similar to other sections we
want to have two buttons the first one
is going to say try me
and here we're going to have a class
name
of a button simply
the second button is going to be called
top
and the class name is going to be back
button
the first button is gonna trigger the
preview mode of your 3D model object and
the second one is just going to be
scroll back to top
so let's save and see what we have
so let's scroll down
and once again this section is invisible
because we have set opacity to zero and
we're going to use the gcap to animate
and fade in later so let's remove that
opacity rule from the index file
so open the index.css file
and let's search for the display section
and let's find the opacity
and let's remove this just comment out
now if we save this and close it
we should get our text
beautiful
now we're just missing that 3D model
which is actually the most interesting
part of this tutorial
we're going to be using webgi viewer to
display this 3D model to our website
which is powered by 3js
and then we're going to be using the
gsap to animate this model through the
different sections of our website
3D model is already presented in a
repository
if you open the public folder you can
find it here scene Dash black dot glb
but in case you want to find some
additionals or different models I will
show you where you can find them
there are plenty of websites with 3D
models but I found my model here on the
sketchfab.com and this is the model that
we are going to be using in this
tutorial as you may see this is iPhone
13 Pro Max but it will serve the purpose
you can browse this website to find
different models for example we can type
here
keyboard
and then you you get a set of different
3D models
and then when you find the one that you
want
you can just download them so as you can
see here on the bottom you have download
3D model
the format that we need is glb so just
click on the download here
and this model is free but you need to
give attribution to the authors
once you download the file you need to
go over to this web GI website and the
links to all the website are going to be
in the description here we can open this
online viewer for this 3D models just
click on the latest version here
and then we can open even newer version
and just click on OK
and now what we can do is we can just
open up our 3D model and Import in the
viewer here
and there you go
in this viewer there are a couple of
things that might be very useful as you
may see here we have this 3D reflection
and on our website we don't have that
because you want this object maybe to
not have the ground or reflection so how
you can remove it is just go to here to
the scene and you have ground
and you can just uncheck the visible and
there you go
also here you will be defining the
initial position of the actual 3D model
on your website
how you do that is actually go here to
the animations
and you have camera views
and then you can find the camera angle
that you like and you can just click on
ADD current View and it gets saved here
then if you want a second view for
example let's just rotate it
like this maybe and click add current
view now we can rotate to this views
that you just saved so just focus on
next and there you go
so again this is very important so this
is how it's going to appear on your
website once you load this file
once you set your initial the first
position that you want you want to go
here to the export
and we have here
assets export and glb Export because
we're going to be using this glb file
and also you want to click here on the
drag or compress
and you just click on the export glp
we're not going to be exporting this
file because we're going to use the
iPhone that I have found and I also
already optimized this asset for you
guys so basically I just removed
uh the ground so if I go to the scene I
just remove the ground and I just
compressed it
also I added the initial the first
position of the actual 3D model
and additionally what's important is
this position and this target values
because these are the values that we are
going to be animating or changing using
the gsop library to rotate and animate
our 3D model
so let's do that
so let's add a new component close this
public folder and inside of the
components let's add a new file a name
of this file is going to be Fab GI V
over
.jsx
now let's import react from the top and
let's create new functional component
and this one is going to be called
web
GI Uber
and here in the return statement let's
add a div
and let's add an ID
here
it is going to be web GI Dash canvas
Dash container
and we're gonna use this ID to apply
some styles to this container
and inside of this div let's add a
canvas
let's add an ID
and the idea is web GI canvas
and let's add ref
we're gonna render our 3D model inside
of this canvas and we're going to use
this ref as a reference so as a place
where we can render the 3D model as well
and for the ID we're going to use to
apply some Styles so let's import graph
on the top
so import
use ref
from react if you're unfamiliar with
user app hook all this hook does is it
gets reference to an HTML element and
then you can perform Dom manipulations
using this reference
so let's call this hook inside of our
component so just call use ref and set
the value as null this is the initial
value and it will return in reference so
we want to store that inside of the
canvas graph this is the name of our
reference and now we can use this
reference and pass this to the ref
parameter of our canvas
and then we're going to be using this
camera strap to initialize the 3D model
and render it inside of this ref
next the great thing about webgi is that
they have a starter code for us so we
actually start developing faster so if
you click here on the get started
here if you scroll a little bit down you
have this web GI starter template on the
GitHub so click on the that link
and you get redirected to the GitHub
webgi vanilla starter this is great but
we cannot reuse this entire project
because we are building this in react
and this is vanilla starter project so
we're just going to borrow some of the
code so go to the source folder and go
to the index.ts file
first let's copy the Imports
they have in this file so copy that
and let's head over to webgi viewer and
let's paste this
and these are all the plugins that you
use in the webgi viewer to apply some
different effects and achieve some
different styles
so let's remove the ones that we are not
going to be using
we are not going to be using timeout
we also don't need this diamond plugin
let's remove this Frame fade plugin as
well
let's remove this one gltf animation
plugin
we don't even need this ground plugin
either
we need this bloom
we don't need this temporal
plugin
we can remove this one as well
we need this one
and we can use this one as well
for the rest of this one we can remove
and let's add a couple of these that
we're gonna actually be using in our
application
mobile and tablet checks so this one
you're going to be using to check if
you're on mobile or tablet so that we
can optimize the position of our models
now let's format this and let's add
additional Imports once we are here so
here let's add additional hooks that
we're going to be using so we're gonna
need use stat hook as well
we're gonna use use callback
you're going to need forward ref and
use imperative handle as well
for animating all of this we're gonna
use gsap so import
GSAT from gsap and let's import
scroll trigger so import scroll trigger
from gsap scroll trigger
instead of all it needs to be scroll
trigger like this
now let's copy the setup function
scroll a little bit down and here async
function this function initialize the
viewer
so let's just copy it and adjust it to
our needs
for react
here just copy
and let's paste it inside of our
function here
let's first check what this code does
we can see here that this is
asynchronous function
and on the next line we are initializing
the viewer so we call the new viewer app
method and we are saving that into the
viewer constant and then we're passing
the canvas argument and here they are
using this document that get element by
ID but actually we're going to use the
camera strap that we just created
so we can just replace that
kind of strap.current
next they are adding some basic plugins
here using this add plugin method on the
viewer and they're storing these values
in the manager
following that they are adding a pop-up
here to show the download progress you
can remove this one as we don't want
this to be displayed
next they are adding some base plugins
using the viewer
and once all the plugins have been added
they are calling this viewer.render
refresh pipeline so basically to load
all the plugins
and then below that they're adding the
3D model from the path let's update this
for us it's going to be
scene Dash black dot glb because we are
writing this from the public folder
and at the bottom they're adding some
additional UI plugins these plugins
would add an interface to your website
like UI panel which you can use to
update and modify your 3D model on the
website but that's not what we want so
let's remove that
and since we're gonna have a lot of
re-rendering on this component I want to
Cache this function using the use
callback hook
this way it's not going to be recreated
every single time that we re-render our
component
so
let's remove that and let's call it use
callback
use callback hook Xbox
an async function
and at the end we provide the list of
the dependencies when we want to
recreate this function but it's going to
be empty because we don't want to
recreate this function
now let's just copy the function that we
already have here
and replace the one inside of the use
callback function or actually hook now
let's format this document
foreign
actually we are missing the equal sign
here
and now we can format the document
and let's preview
but before we can preview we actually
need to call this function and we can do
that inside of a user effect look
so in use effect we will just
call this setup viewer function
and we want to do this only once so
pass an empty array of dependency lists
now let's save this and let's preview
so let's open the app.jsx file and let's
import this component
here in the import section
type in import
webgi viewer from components slash web
GI viewer and let's display it here
make it a soft close inside similar to
others
so let's save
and let's open our website
but actually see that we have an error
so let's open up the console
and inside of the console
we have this canvas snip plug-in is not
defined so probably we are missing the
import let's go back and let's add it
so here in the webgl viewer
we are adding this plugin but we are
probably not importing it so let's add
it here in the import section
let's save it and let's refresh and boom
as you saw for a second let me just
refresh it
there you go this is our phone but now
we need to adjust the animation so this
is the initial position and also we need
to clip the background because this one
has a black background which is covering
our navigation on top so let's do that
here in webgi viewer let's scroll a
little bit down after the import here of
the manager so let's add viewer
dot get plugin
and the plugin that we need to do this
is tone map plugin
and we're going to set the configuration
and the clip background is the property
that we want to update we want to clip
the background and set just to true
and if we save this in preview you can
see that now we see our background and
actually background is transparent and
we can see the navigation on top
so now let's do a little bit of cleanup
of this file because there is a lot of
comments that we don't need and we can
remove that and add the stuff that you
need
let's remove this comment here
I will remove this one as well here
and let's add some plugins that we have
imported so we need this one
GB buffer plugin
let's uncomment all of these because we
will need them as well
we also need this Bloom plugin
so adding these plugins to change the
appearance of the 3D model and we're
only including the ones that we need
okay
we are not adding the base plugins
anymore because we are adding them
individually
and here we also need to remove this one
because we are adding again the plugins
individually I can remove this comment
and let me see on the import section so
we don't need any more add the base
plugins
and we don't need this canvas snipper
plugin either
this one we're going to be using later
to determine whether we are on tablet
mobile or desktop
let's clean up a little bit more as well
we don't need any of these comments
and now let's add one more command so I
want to disable the controls once we
load our viewer so set the viewer
scene
DOT active camera
dot set camera options so here we want
to set the camera options and we want to
use controls enable and I want to set it
to false
so what it means is we are disabling the
controls so the users are not able to
rotate the 3D model once the website is
loaded
next whenever we reload our website I
want the position of our page to be on
top so let's add window dot scroll to
insert the top and left to zero so that
we are always at the top position of our
website and we can start with the
animation now I want to add an event
listener to the viewer itself
what this listener will do once it's
fired off it will update the position of
the camera if update is needed so type
the following viewer dot add event
listener and the name of the listener is
pre-frame
once that fire off we want to execute
this callback function
and here we want to update our camera
but in order to update our camera we
actually need to get our active camera
first so we do that here
before all these plugins that you're
adding here let's add new constant and
here we will save our camera so we
access the camera by viewer dot scene
DOT active camera
and using this camera we can access the
position and the target so let's do that
as well click once position
equals the camera
dot position
and the target is const
ant Target
is equal to camera dot Target
using these three properties that we
just got from the camera and the viewer
we're gonna modify and animate our 3D
model because changing the view and the
Target and the position of that you're
actually getting that 3D rotation
animation model so let's update the
camera here
and once this event listener has been
fired off we want to call camera
dot position Target updated and set that
to true
but we want only to update this in
certain conditions so let's create a
variable
and name it as needs update
and set it to
just make sure that spelling is correct
it's
update and set that to true
and we want to make a shack inside of
the listener if
it needs update
then we want to update the camera
position
and set
flag to defaults
like so
let's format the document
and let's save and let's see if we have
any errors so far
and as you can see the background clip
doesn't work anymore so let's fix that
the issue is probably with the tone
mapping plugin because it adds some
stuff which disables the transparency so
let's remove this argument and let's
just add it true
save that and let's preview again
and this works correctly now so now what
we want to do is once we click on the
learn more we want this mobile to rotate
and to set into this position here so
let me just zoom out a little bit so
it's at 100
and once we click on the learn more it
will rotate and move on the right side
here so let's do that
we are going to be using gsap and we
already imported the gsap and the scroll
trigger plugin so let's register that
plugin call the gsap
.register
plugged in and just pass in the name of
the scroll because this is the animation
that is going to be triggered on the
scroll itself
now I want to create new file where I
will be saving this animation as I want
to break down this file bit because it's
becoming very large so add a new folder
inside of the source folder
and name this one as Loop
which stands for Library
and let's add a new file the name of
this file is going to be scroll Dash
animation.js
first we will need gsap here as well so
import gsap from
gsap
like so
let's create a scroll animation function
and Export it so type in export const
scroll animation
this is going to be a fat Arrow function
and here we're going to receive some of
the arguments so first we're going to
receive the camera position
then camera Target
then we're going to receive on update
we are going to be using this method to
update the position of the camera every
time we added the parameters of our
camera we will call this method to
update it and re-render
so let's create a new timeline for the G
sub so let's hit TL for timeline and
let's execute the jsop.timeline
function
but before we add the animation let's
first import this function inside of the
webgi viewer and pass all the arguments
that we need for the animation so that
we can see what we are changing while we
are coding the animation
so let's import the function here on the
top
and make sure actually to save the file
here first
and then import
animation from lib slash scroll
animation
and again as you don't want to re-render
and recreate this animation function on
every render let's use a callback to
Cache it and memorize it so add a new
variable const memorize
scroll animation
and we're going to use use callback
again to memorize this function
here we're going to receive position
Target
and on update
and we're just gonna check if these
three exist so if
we have position
and we have Target
and we have on update
then we want to call our our scroll
animation function
and pass all the all the three arguments
here
and we want to execute this only once so
pass the empty array of the dependencies
and now let's call this function
here
on the very end
after the event listener let's call our
function and now let's pass the
arguments so first we want to pass the
position this is the position of the
camera and we Define it here
we Define the position and the target of
the camera
so we are passing in the position and
the Target and the last one is we need
to create new own update method for
updating our camera view so let's create
it const
on update this is a simple fed Arrow
function
and we just want to update this needs
update here
set it to true
and we want to Mark the camera
or actually the viewer as dirty so
viewer
dot set dirty this basically says that
the camera and the viewer needs to be
updated that's all it does
and now let's pass this method here to
the memoize scroll animation
there you go and now let's go back to
the scroll animation.js file and let's
start with our animation here
and now on the GSAT timeline we want to
execute to function so this function
takes the parameters of what we want to
animate but first we want to animate the
position of the camera
and as a second argument it receives an
object and inside of this object we want
to define a trigger what will trigger
the animation and the properties that we
want to change for us in this animation
when we are scrolling we are starting
the animation so set the scroll trigger
property and we Define here a new object
inside of this object the first property
that you want to Define is the actual
trigger so this needs to be the element
that is triggering this animation the
element in the Dom itself for us this is
the sound section so type in the sound
section
and where I found this class let me show
you
so if you go to our browser
if we inspect
developer tools you can see here they
have this sound section and this is the
second section here this one
so we want this section to trigger the
animation
the next property is when we want to
start the trigger so type in start
and we want to start when the top of
this section
hits the bottom of the viewport
so let me just show you what I mean by
that
let me close to browser console tools
and here
this is the top section
of the sound system this right here this
line and the bottom part of the viewport
is this
so this is static actually this Top Line
is static it's always there but the
bottom of the viewport is changing once
we start scrolling so when we start
scrolling it's changing and basically at
this first scroll this is already
reached the top and this is when we want
to fire off our animation
here also we need to Define what will
end the animation so we set the end
property when the top of the sounds
section this reaches the top
of the viewport
so again let's review that
top of the viewport
is right here
and the top of the sound section is
right here so when these two meet we
reached the end of the animation so if
we scroll
and when we reach
this position position when the top of
the viewport reaches the top of this
sound section the animation should be
ended
and now if we update our position camera
position and we'll leave it like that we
will only have the start and end
position and there will not be any
transition in between so we need to use
the scrub property
you can set the scrub to true
this way the 3D model will be changing
its position from start to the end
position using the scroll position so
but if you want to add a little bit of
delay
you can add numbers here so I tried a
couple of numbers and I found it too
works the best
if this animation is very heavy on our
browser we need to do a little bit of
implementation for the performance so we
can pass in immediate render as false
this means that you are not going to try
to render this animation until it's
actually triggered
and once the animation is done we want
to call this on update method
and if you don't remember what this
method does so let's go back here all
this method does it sets this flag to
true and says the viewer to set 30. so
it means the viewer needs to be updated
and then we trigger this event listener
and then the camera position gets
updated here
and now we need to set the values that
we are going to be changing so we have X
y and z
and where we get these values is from
the webgi viewer so let's do that
so we need to open the webgi viewer and
then you need to import the 3D model
that you're going to be using in your
application
to get the position of camera you need
to go to the animations
and then what you want to do is you want
to position the 3D model the way you
want it to look
so you basically want to position the
end position for your 3D model
once you do that you can go and click
here on ADD current View
a new camera view has been added here in
the list
you can expand that
and you can see that here we got the
position of the camera and target of the
camera so we have the x y z values and
we can use these values to animate and
add them to the gsap so this animation
will have this position as end
and once you add all the position that
you want you can basically just go and
keep rotating the animation that's all
we want to do in our application to
rotate the views that we saved in our
glb file and retrieve this information
and store them in the gsap animation
function so let's do that
I already tested the positions that I
want for my mobile 3D model so let's
just type them in the X position should
be minus 3.38
the Y position should be -10.74
and the set should be minus
5.93 and now I want to execute exactly
the same function but on the camera
Target so we can reuse this code
just add this function here
and for the second one we want to remove
the on update because it's enough to
call this function only once
and we want to update the element is
Target
here
now let's update the values that we got
for the Target
for the X
is going to be 1.52
40y we're going to set
0.77 and for the set
let's add minus 1.08
and again I'm not coming up with these
numbers randomly but I was playing
around with the 3D model and I found
that this position is a position that I
want to have at the end of this
animation so let's save this
and let's try it out
let's open the browser and if you click
on the learn more
boom we get our animation and if we
scroll up the animation starts as well
the problem is here that as you can see
that this image is covering our 3D model
so what we can do is we can change the
opacity and Fade Out this all content I
mean the other solution could be that we
place the 3D model on top of this
content but I would like to fade in
anyways so let's do that
again we can reuse the same function
that we called so let me just copy paste
this
and now the target is going to be the
jumble transaction
so let's type in shambotron
Dash section
and here we don't want to update any
positions but actually we want to fade
out so set the opacity to zero like so
the trigger will remain the same so
let's try that
and now if you scroll
it's actually not working so let me
check if the selector is correct
so as you can see here we are missing o
so it should be a Jumbotron section so
if you go back and if we inspect this
section so let me just show you can see
that this is the the target CSS Target
that we want to use
okay let's try now
we scroll now you can see that it's
fading away and we get this nice effect
but what we also want to do is we want
to fade in this new sound system so this
section should be fading as well so
let's do that
first let's open index.css file and
let's find the not the space section but
actually we want sound section sound
Dash section
and let's find here opacity so we want
to set the initial opacity to be zero
and as you can see here
when we get to that position we don't
see anything but now we want to fade in
so let's add the fading animation
so here we can reuse again the same code
so just copy this function and paste and
this time we want to trigger sound
section content or actually we want to
animate the sound section content and
the trigger is again sound section
here we want to set the opacity to 1.
because we want to fade in
there are rest of the animation should
be remained the same so let's try now
let's see and let's reload
and click on learn more
and there you go you see how it's
animating once you start scrolling down
here is semi-transparent and then we
reach the final position it's fully
fully solid great so let's continue
now we want to add the last piece of the
puzzle so once we click on the learn
more here we want to get scroll to the
bottom and we want to animate but as you
can see we haven't implemented this
scroll at all so let's go back to this
field of Base sound system section and
let's implement this first learn more
and then we can animate this phone so
let's do that
let me close all these files
and let's open the sound section here
I want to add new function
and let's name this function as
const
handle learn more and this is going to
be fair Arrow function
first we want to get a reference to the
last section and we can store that
inside of the element
so Define const element
and then using the document
query selector
we can Target the display section
which is the last section so let me show
you
so right click and let's inspect
and you can see this is the display
section which is the last section of the
website which we want to Target
okay and now we want to scroll to that
element so call the window dot scroll to
and pass in an object with the
parameters for the top we want to use
the element
and we want to get bound
the client Direct
and we want the bottom position
we want to set the Left To Zero because
we don't have any horizontal scroll and
for the behavior you want to set this
mode
and let's use this method or actually
function
and pass it here to learn more
so Define new event handler on click and
just pass this function
let's try it out
so scroll a little bit up and let's
click on the learn more
and there you go
beautiful now we should add the
animation for this 3D model
so let's open our
lib scroll animation.js file and again
we can reuse
this uh this entire function so we
actually can copy the both of this
position
because we're going to update the
position and the target as well for the
third animation
first we need to update the trigger
because we the trigger right now is the
last section so
display Dash section it's not the sound
section anymore
so the same for the last one
and now let's just update the values
so for x
1.56
for y 5.0 and for its set
0.01
and for the Target
X is going to be minus 0.55
0.32 for y and for the set
you want to set 0.0
like so let's save and let's see what we
have
if you click on the first learn more we
get animation to the second section and
if you click on the next learn more
we get the animation for the last
section beautiful and you see how easy
it is to add this animation effect using
gsap and 3js and you can also do the
custom scrolling and you can see that
the animation is changing while you're
scrolling this is just outstanding
the only thing that I want here is I
want this section to fit in as well so
let's add this animation
we can actually reuse the animation from
The Sound section so let's just copy
that
and let's add it here on the bottom
here I just want to change the target
for the last action it's going to be
space section
without the content here
and let's update the trigger as well
it is also display section
like so
let me save and let's see
once again click on the learn more
in here
but actually we forgot to set the
opacity initially to zero so let's find
the display section
if I can write it correctly
and let's find it here so set the
opacity to zero initially
let's save it and let's try
so let's refresh the page
click on the learn more
once again and there you go you have
this nice animation fade in as you can
see it's semi-transparent here and once
we start scrolling it gets fully visible
and solid beautiful
the next thing that I want to do is I
want to implement this try me to get
that preview mode where you can play
around with this 3D model and I want to
implement this top so that we get scroll
to the top of the page so let's first
implement this topic because it's the
easiest one
let's first close all these files
close all these files and let's open the
display section here
let's add another function
and let's name this function as handle
scroll
to talk
and this is going to be fat Arrow
function again
and all we want to do is to scroll to
top so use the window Dot scroll to
and we want to set the top to zero left
to zero and set the behavior to smooth
like so
and now we can use this function
and pass to this button so let's call
the on click event and pass this
function
beautiful let's try it
so if you click on top
nice that's exactly what you wanted to
do now let's implement this try me
preview mode
so what we need to do is we need to add
on click eventually Center on this
button and once we click on this button
we want to fire our function from the
pair component parent component is
app.jsx file here
and then inside of this function we want
to fire off another function and that
last function is going to be inside of
this webgi viewer so let's start from
that
in order to reference a function from
this component we need to use forward
graph use hook so let's rename this
function to use this hook
so instead of the function let's write
const we have gi viewer and we're going
to use
forward graph
and forward graph takes two arguments
the first one is the properties and the
second one is the reference
and we just need to wrap our component
with this four draft hook so let's copy
the component
and let's place it in here
and now what we need to do is we need to
use use imperative handle hook
so let's write
here
use imperative hand hook and inside of
this hook we're gonna Define what is the
function that we're going to trigger
from the air component
here we receive
Fair Arrow function
and
the name of the function can be
trigger preview
and in order to enable this animation
you basically need to have the reference
to the camera to the Target to the
position all these informations and this
is inside of the setup user so we need
to create another variable and store all
of this inside of the variable so that
we can access them inside of this
trigger preview so let's add the
reference to them
we will use use statehope for that
so let's create first one const
viewer
ref this is the name of our variable
that we're going to use to store the
viewer now let's set the setter function
so set viewer graph
and just use the use State hook
to set the initial value to zero or
actually to null
let's copy paste this a couple of times
because we're going to do the same for
the Target
so copy the target
and here we want to set the set function
as set-sided ref
and then we want to update the third one
which is for the camera
and update the setter function
should be set camera ref
the next one is position ref
position wrap and
the setup function is set position Raw
like so
and now we can use these variables and
use the gsap to change the position of
our camera
because as you can see on the last
position this is the camera or actually
3D model position when you click on try
me we want to change the position of
this phone to face us and be a little
bit smaller something like similar like
here or actually on the first position
something more similar like this
position so that's what we are going to
be doing
so let's call the gsap
.2 this is the function again and we are
now changing the position route
and we want to pass in X again x y
that's it
and values are going to be
4X 13.
or Y is going to be minus 2.01 and for
the set it's going to be 2.29
and for the duration let's set it
duration to two
and at the end we want to call on update
because we want to update the position
once we set the values
we actually want to re-render the camera
view and 3D model so call the unupdate
which receives a function as a callback
and we want to set the viewer app to be
dirty set dirty this means that we are
marking the viewer for rendering
and then let's call the camera ref
position
Target updated and set it to true
so basically we're saying that the
position of the target has been updated
and we need to do the same for the
Target
so again let's call gsap.2
and this time we need Target ref
and again position where X is going to
be zero point
one one where the Y is going to be 0.0
to the set is going to be 0.0 and set
the duration to B2
just make sure to put the column in
between
and now we should be able to call this
function from the parent
so let me open the app.jsx and first we
need to create a user ref reference to
this function so use ref
call this one and let's store that
inside of the const webgi
viewer rack
foreign
and now we can connect
our reference to the component so use
the ref
property and I just pass the subject
that we created
like so and now let's define a new
function that you'll be triggering from
this display section
let's name it
can look preview
it is going to be a fat Arrow function
and we're going to access the method
from the webgl viewer
so X is the ref
dot current
and the name of the function that you
define here is trigger preview
like so
and we are going to trigger this
function from the display section so
let's add another property
and call it trigger preview and let's
just pass the handle preview function
now let's call this trigger preview
property inside of the display section
here
and make sure to destructure it now
let's add an event handler here on try
me button so let's add on click
and just call this function
let's format the document
let's save this one
let's format this one and actually let's
format this one as well
let's save all of them and let's try
and obviously we have an error so let's
inspect to see what's happening
and we have user app is not defined so
let's import user
so here in the app.jsx
let's import
loose wrap Hook from react
let's save it
and let's try now
so in our our application is not broken
anymore so let's write try me
but it's not working for some reason so
let me inspect
let's see the console
and you cannot read properties of null
inside of the web Java viewer okay so
that we are actually not storing these
values viewer app Camera
and position wrap and Charlie graph we
only created these values
but we never assign them so let's do
that we forgot this step
let's close this
let's open the web Java viewer
and here let's scroll a bit down
here we are setting the viewer let's
initialize and store it inside of our
variable so set viewer ref and just pass
in the viewer
and now let's do the same
for the camera so let's find where the
camera is
okay so it's here camera position and
Target
so let's call it set camera ref
I'm passing the camera
and we want to set position ref
and press into position
and set the target graph
in crossing the target
like so
we are basically calling this set
function
and storing the reference to these
variables
so that we can use them inside of this
trigger preview
just for reminder okay let's try now
let's scroll down
and let's scroll to the end and now
let's click on try me
and there you go we have animated this
3D model iPhone to have this front
facing position the next thing that I
want to do is I want to enable this to
be rotated and I want to hide all these
things behind this this iPhone so let's
do that
let's open the app.jsx file and let's
add a container here for all of these
sections so we can hide them
so let's add another div
and let's add ideal content
and let's add a reference
to add a ref and let's make a new
reference
let's call it three smart as content
ref
and call the use refwork again
so we're going to use this ref to hide
all this content
so pass the ref
variable to this content and let's move
in all these sections here
so what we are going to do is just to
fade away all these sections once we are
in a preview mode and that's it and this
webgl viewer will be only viewable on
the website
so let's do that
let's pass this reference to the webgr
viewer
add new property and call this on
content ref
and just pass in the content graph
here now let's open the web job viewer
component
now let's just access
from the properties so call the props
Dot contentrev
set the current
Style
and opacity
to zero
like so so let's try that
and now if we scroll to the bottom of
the website
and let's click on the try me
we can see that all elements have
disappeared apart from the 3D model
now we want to be able to rotate this
model but at the moment the pointer
events are disabled for this section so
if you go to the canvas you can see the
pointer events are set to none so we
want to fix this
and to enable rotation so let's do that
so let's add another reference to the
container of the canvas
let's store it inside of the constant
and let's call this one canvas
container
and again we're going to use use refwork
and the initial value is going to be
null
now we want to pass this to our canvas
container so scroll down
to the canvas and let's use the wrap and
pass this reference here
now we can use this
to update it once we call the trigger
preview
so here let's call it and let's add the
current dot style dot pointer events
and equals to all
this will remove the pointer events rule
that we set earlier but what we also
need to do is we want to set and enable
a 3D model to be rotated so we do that
here and set the viewer ref dot scene
DOT active camera
and set camera options
we want to reset this back to controls
enabled to true
and this will enable the rotation
of the 3D model so let's save it and
let's preview
let's scroll to the bottom of the page
once again let's click try me
and let's try to roll and there you go
now we are able to control the 3D model
how exciting is this
you can zoom in
zoom out change the position to whatever
you want and inspect this 3D model
this is outstanding
but there is one problem we cannot exit
this preview mode so we need to add
another button here and once we click on
the button we want to close
this preview mode and return everything
back to the normal so let's do that
so we need to create another flag
variable to be able to distinguish when
we are in preview mode and we are not
so Define const
in the array
preview mode
and set preview mode
you're gonna use the use that hook
and set initial value to be false so at
the beginning we are not in the preview
mode
and now when we call this trigger
preview method or function rather we
want to set this preview mode to be true
so call the set preview mode and passing
true
and now depending on this model we want
to show or hide the button that we're
going to add here
in the containers so let's add
expression and let's see if the preview
mode
is true if it's true we want to render
this button
so add a button
and this button will just say exit
let's set a class name
of Simply button like so
let's save it
and let's see what we got here
so refresh the page
let's scroll to the bottom of the page
click on the try me and there you go now
let's implement the exit
so let's add a new on click event
handler on the exit button so on click
and we will create new function
and let's call this function handle head
is it
like so and let's define it here
so up to the hook here
and we're going to use use callback
because let's save it and we don't want
to recreate this function all over again
whenever we're rendering the component
so we're calling this one as hand exit
and we're going to use use callback hook
and you're gonna receive this function
inside of it
and we're going to pass an array of
dependencies later
so what we want to do in this function
is we want to reset the state that we
set here in this trigger preview so we
can reuse the code that we defined here
let's copy this one
and let's paste it here
we want to set the pointer events back
to none
and we want to set the opacity of the
content graph
to 1 as well and also we want to disable
here
controls for the rotating the 3D model
so let's reset them back
set the controls enable to false
let's also set the preview mode
to false
so that we hide the button
and now we need to position our iPhone
or 3D model back to its original
position and we already defined its
position inside of the
leave scroll animation so we can reuse
that code
so you're going to find the Target and
the opacity
or actually this is for the display
section so here the target
and the position
so let's copy this
and let's paste it here
called the gsap
and call it to or actually we copied to
Method as well
let me just close the folders and let me
format this
and let's just update the position
because here we are using the reference
to the position
and also let's update the target to ref
and let's update this method on update
method so we need to find that
let's pass in a function and inside of
this function we're going to call EUR
and we're going to set 30.
again something Simon that we already
did and we want to call the camera ref
and let's set the position Target
updated to true
like so
and we want to update this function only
with certain dependencies are updated so
canvas container ref
usition ref
camera ref
and Target draft
and let's just not forget to call the
GSAT
on the second animation as well and we
can close to the previous one
perfect let's save this and let's
preview
let's open the browser
let's scroll to the bottom of our page
and let's click on try me
now we are in preview mode so we can
scroll play around or actually rotate
and click on the exit
and boom we are back at the initial
position
you can open the preview mode when we
want
zoom in play around
do whatever we want and click on the
exit
and you're back excellent
and the next thing that I want to do is
optimize this for mobile devices so
let's open the console tools so inspect
and let's open up the simulator here on
the right top
let's refresh
and as you can see this doesn't look
correct so we want to update the
positions of our preview model so let's
do that
we already are importing
function to help us to determine this
mobile intelligent check so let's add
another flag which will be used to store
the results of the mobile and tablet
check
so let's set up lag type in const is
mobile and the setup function will be
set is mobile
and we're going to use u-state hook
obviously to store the state and set to
no first
next
in setup Uber
here next reset your ref we want to call
this function so mobile
and double check and we want to store
the result in a constant
name this one is mobile
or tablet
like so
and to be able to access this variable
outside of this function we want to
store that
to our state variable so set is
mobile as well to
this constant
so now we can access that through the
entire functional component that we have
here
and now let's scroll a little bit down
and here below this controls that we are
disabling controls we want to check
if
is mobile or tablet
if it is we want to reset the position
and Target to fit the mobile phone so
use the position to set
to
-16 point
seven
the second one is going to be 1.17 in
the third one
11.7 again I was playing around with
this
with these positions and these values to
set the one that corresponds to the
resolution that I need for the mobile
phone
then we want to set the target as well
set the first to zero for the X for y
set the one point
30. 7 and the last one set to zero
and we want to add additional class to
our content draft so use the props Dot
contentref
dot current
dot class name
and set the class to mobile Dash or Dash
tablet
using this class we're going to hide the
elements that we don't need on the
mobile phone
so let's save and see if this fixed our
initial position
and there you go it is but if you scroll
down we can see that the second position
and probably the third one are not
working as expected so let's fix them
so we want to pass this flag to memorize
scroll animation as well so let's pass
here is mobile or tablet like so
yeah let's
accept it here
add it here it's a property or actually
as an argument is mobile
and we want to send it here as well so
that we are able to update the positions
okay
and now we can open this inside of our
scroll animation so let's save this
let's format this document
and let's open up the scroll animation
here
so we are receiving another argument
and we call it is mobile
like so
now let's update these values
so let's use the ternary operator to
make this more simple so let's just
check is this not mobile if it's not
Remain the values as they are
if it is let's set the new value
for the first X is going to be
-7
now let's do the same
for the add values
for the second one
if it's on mobile we want to set minus
12.2
like so for the third one
we're gonna set minus 6.0
let's do the same for the Target here
if it's not on mobile
remain the same otherwise set to 0.7
for the Y let's set
the value to be 1.9
and for the last one let's set it to be
0.7
okay let's save
now let's update for the last section
again we want to add this ternary
operator and for the second one we're
going to add
nine point
50.
we're actually 36 sorry
for the Y we want to add a value of
10.95 if it's on mobile
and for the set you want to set a
position to be 0.09 on mobile
and let's set the target for the display
section as well here
if you are on the mobile we want to set
the position to be minus 1.62
then for the Y
we want to set position to be 0.02
and for the last one we want to set
position to be minus 0.06
let's save this and let's see what we
got
let's open the browser
and let's refresh the page
and if you click on the learn more
we can see that we get the correct
position for the second section and
let's see in the last section
great this looks awesome so what if we
click on try me
okay this looks a little bit different
but if we click on the exit we can see
that this value remained the same so
let's update that one
let's open the webgi viewer and we do
that here in the handle exit function
so again let's add
again this ternary operator and let's
check if it's not on mobile we're
setting this value as it is but if it's
on mobile you want to set 9.36
for the second one we're gonna set
10.95
for the last one is going to be 0.09
this is for the position and for the
Target let's have it as well
so we're gonna say minus
6.62 40 y
let's set
0.02
and for the last Z
let's set
the value to be -0 point
0 6.
like so let's save and let's format
again
actually we have this L we don't need
that so let's remove the L and once
again let's format
and let's preview what we have
and once again let's scroll to the
bottom of our website
let's click on try me
this looks fine and let's click on the
exit
and boom we are back at the right
position outstanding so let's scroll to
the top and the last piece of the puzzle
and the last piece of the website that I
want to add
is the loader because this animation is
very very heavy on the performance of
the website itself so we want to give
some time the website and the assets to
load in and display some nice animation
for the user as well so they don't have
to you know just see and wait and look
at black so let's do that
let's close all these files
and let's add a new component in the
component section so add a new file and
name this file as loader.jsx
let's import react on top
and let's create functional component
name it folder
here we're just gonna import a gif image
and display that so let's import
animated
logo
from
assets slash Images slash logo Dash
animated
dot GIF so this is already placed in the
assets folder we just need it to load it
and in the return statement let's add a
div
and this diff has a class name of loader
and let's add an image
let's add a class name of logo
let's add a source
animated logo
and let's add an alt
and set that one too
iPhone
loader
or actually Apple maybe it's about
because we have multiple devices on the
loading animation so let's save this and
let's import this inside of the app.jsx
file
let's import it in the import section
here
import
order from components for slash loader
and let's place it here
and make it a self-closing tag
let's save and see what we have
now let's reload the page
and boom we have this nice loading
animation and after couple of seconds it
fades away
if you're wondering how this Fade Away
animation is being done let me show you
so let's open the index.css file and
let's find this
let's search for DASH loader class and
as you can see I'm using the animation
called Fade Out and this is just a
simple CSS animation so we are fading
from opacity 1 to opacity zero and we
are holding this GIF for three seconds
and after three seconds you're firing
this animation which actually Fades away
in 0.3 seconds and that's all it does
and with that we completed our website
now let's build and deploy this project
so head over to our Visual Studio code
and let's open up the terminal
I want to open another terminal and
let's actually open up a bash let's
close the Powershell and let's close the
first batch
and now simply just run npm run build
make sure to spell it correctly
and this will build a static folder for
us and we can use this folder to upload
to the hosting and it's done that was
very fast and as you can see we have
this this folder and we can upload that
so let me do that let's head over to the
browser and let's open netlify.com
website
and you want to create account here
everything is free so you don't have to
worry about that go to the login
and now let's add a new site here on the
top right add a new site and we want to
deploy manually or deploy actually so
click here on the browse to upload and
in the download section for me
I want to click on the list folder so
let's upload it click on the upload
and let's wait for a couple of seconds
depending on your connection and there
you go it was very fast now what we can
do is this is the URL of our application
we can change that so go to the site
settings and let's change the site name
so we can type something as Apple
iPhone website
so that we have much nicer URL so let's
save that
and let's click on the site to preview
it
and it's beautiful it's working
and there you go
this is astonishing
so let's sum up what we did and what we
created so we created these beautiful
animations which changes these three
positions and at the end we created this
preview mode as well which is
astonishing really
also we added this loading animation
indicator at the beginning of our
website
and what we also did is we optimized
this for mobile devices
and obviously you could spend even more
time to optimize this website for
different devices right but that wasn't
the purpose of this tutorial the purpose
of this tutorial was to show you how to
animate 3D objects inside of your
website and there are some edge cases
probably on this website that needs to
be handled in regards to the layout and
optimization
I hope you guys learned something new
and if you want to support me and get
the full source code of this tutorial go
check my patreon at
patreon.com forward slash code with
sloba or if this tutorial reaches 1000
views I will release the full source
code on my GitHub also if you get stuck
during the development of this project
you can get my help so check the
advanced tiers on my patreon as well
also I have private one-on-one chat
where I can help you and support you on
this project
until the next time happy coding